tchénio propose voyage sans passeport
sur des images de l'ex michelet en
compagnie d'yves annales
oh
e
en plein coeur d'amsterdam
ivan lendl sur la lettre se plainent la
place de l'aide
voici le théâtre municipal à gauche
voilà les trams hollandais 60 kilomètres
à l'heure oui moderne et têtu nom et
avec des frais nostre un freinage très
puissant il y as d'estrées souvent une
boîte aux lettres à l'arrière surtout
les trams qui vont vers la gare ça c'est
le toit du théâtre c'est le centre
intellectuel de la ville artistique et
la plaine oui oui il a aussi des
étudiants jour temps oui ils se
réunissent dans de nombreux cafés
écrivain étudiants artistes oui
la circulation est assez intense et
cette dame n'a dû être à présent elle se
fait un peu sinon c'est que je crois
c'est engager trop tard sur le passager
brees qui en principe d'une priorité ok
tu en voilà
vous payez la reconduite pas quand il ya
des feux et par la magie de l'image nous
sommes maintenant en plein coeur d'un
musée de la marine
et il nous raconte beaucoup d'histoires
un globe terrestre du 16e siècle
et les collections de différents types
de navires surtout des anciens des
sourds voile
si le modèle du vaisseau amiral hollande
y à 2663 que commandèrent les amiraux
trompe et de reuter lui c'est
extrêmement trouvera je jette un travail
gigantesque no spam que de travail que
de détail et les canaux en quantité il y
en avait quelques fois 120 150 même sur
les bateaux de commerce qui devait se
défendre des pirates et des corses elle
même consiste à mettre de commerce à
celui des indes orientales peut-être
c'est possible oui il avait la dure de
bateaux de guerre
oui en tout cas elles sont extrêmement
richement sculpté et c'est un petit peu
en allant dans ces endroits que l'on se
rend compte à quel point la hollande a
pu vivre paris sur la mer n'est ce pas
un jour où il a dû faire rêver quelques
marins encre touche qui touche à la mer
qui rapporte
on croirait vraiment que c'est un gros
voilà ils ne sont pas petit du reste ils
sont vraiment déjà très important ce
sont de véritables châteaux sur l'eau
oui mais enluminés regarder ça on dirait
à me feront temps d'une maison ont
validé les fenêtres à petit tout à fait
dans le style louis xiv pas du tout
c'était un bateau elle des canons caché
celui ci caché son jeu vous voyez rien
et ça m'arrivait ça c'est extraordinaire
c'est ce qui représentait les ponts
votre choix
et maintenant voici les tableaux de la
bataille navale oui c'est laid le fameux
l apostrophe y devant amsterdam et
paysages d'hiver de l'un vers cam je
crois
le signe enragé de yann asline et ce
tous ces tableaux progressons du muséum
du musée national
ça c'est la dre sur les berges et
terrestres
chalonnais du 16e siècle sont à peu près
oui et maintenant c'est un tough to st
jean n'est ce pas comme en reprenant oui
c'est parti d'un tableau qui l'apparenté
de la vierge entre viège et cette main
préfigure un visage celui d'anna code
morten femmes aiment ce mr heemskerk
toujours du 16e
et cette fillette edith fille en bleu se
faire prendre
et d'une main à l'autre pour arriver
jusqu'à celle de m elisabeth ya comme
basse
ce monsieur et soeurs thomas grisham oui
d'antonio mouvaux un goya like ou d'en
ramener et voici from south wii et son
joyeux buveurs et alep réjouis d'une en
effet ça se former chez seagate c'est la
ronde de nuit n'est ce pas avant une
nuit où la compagnie du capitaine bad
cop
car il était une prise d'armes de jours
oui et ça c'est la fameuse notions
d'anatomie professeur dé mam
oui il y en a une au travail et wiltord
en bande de gamins
son fils titus ucu ce site us en habit
de moine
il avait 19 ans mills avait 19 ans cui
pas rembrandt et le voici quand il
commençait à être un ps jean brun jeunes
et ceci à la rembrandt uys comment
dites-vous une espèce rare entre oui
mais encore en brun habitat 2639 à 1658
est aujourd'hui musée musée avec
beaucoup de gravure et qui a été
reconstitué à peu près dans les temps
anciens dans l'état du temps de
rembrandt sct fausse tout à l'heure ne
lit pas le sacrifice d'abraham
c'est ce que je fais mais je crois que
rembrandt à habiter dans le quartier
juif d'amsterdam et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a beaucoup peint ces types
de visages voyage a été certainement
influencé par le parisien l'ancien
testament par le type hébreu oui
c'est dans cette maison qu'il a vécu
avec d'abord avec sa sicav et on l'a dit
à ce moment-là très heureux titus y est
née en 1641 et saskia est morte l'année
suivante
l'année où il avait lui n'a peint la
ronde de nuit la nuit et bien c'est
chercher trois arbres ils vont de
mailing que je vais vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir bien voulu voyager
avec nous en hollande
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport sur des images d'alex richter
ou compagnie d'ivan ma des montages ray
au script et simone chavaudra son annick
lopez jean claude brisson illustration
sonore dominique paladilhe réalisation
solange péters